nous l'avons appris hier seulement
france gall a été opéré le 22 avril
dernier d'un cancer du sein elle a dû
reporter son spectacle à bercy prévu
pour le mois de juin la chanteuse suit
un traitement de radiothérapie jean
daniel flaysakier le cancer qui frappe
france gall n'est malheureusement pas un
phénomène rare avec 25 mille nouveaux
cas par an le cancer du sein est le
cancer le plus fréquent chez la femme il
mécanisme qui amènent des cellules
normales à ce camp series et commence à
être un petit peu mieux cerner parmi les
facteurs augmentant le risque de cancer
on sait qu'il y à un âge précoce à la
puberté de même qu'une ménopause à un
âge tardif c'est sans doute l'effet de
certaines hormones appelé estrogènes qui
est en cause
ces hormones provoquant la division
rapide et nombreuse des cellules du sein
autre facteur augmentant le risque
l'absence d'enfant ou bien encore une
première grossesse après l'âge de 30 ans
et puis il ya certains facteurs
héréditaires une femme dont la mère la
soeur ou la cousine germaine aura eu un
cancer du sein devra se faire surveiller
de façon particulière pour les autres
femmes celles qui n'appartiennent pas à
ces groupes présumée à risque il est
nécessaire de faire une surveillance
régulière à partir de l'âge de 50 ans au
moyen d'un examen simple une
mammographie
cet examen est aujourd'hui proposé
systématiquement dans de nombreux
départements français